with heightened restrictions and strict
capacity limits many restaurants are
having to get really creative in order
to make ends meet 8 news now reporter
kate houston live at tres casuelas on
spring mountain road in polaris
with the changes they're making kate to
stay open
yes this year restaurants have had to
adapt time and time again in order to
stay
open here at tres casuelas you can see
they built an
outdoor dining area over some parking
spaces this is to increase their
capacity
limit and to offer more options to
guests now the owner angelo reyes says
his business was impacted drastically by
the most recent restrictions
he says all of the costs to keep the
restaurant open including
overhead and labor is far more expensive
than what 25 percent capacity brings in
reyes and his team had to get creative
with the limitations that they had
in just five days they were able to
build this outdoor patio
which reyes calls a new era of dining he
says while it was a bit of a rush
decision
it's been a game changer a push for us
to be more aggressive
and invest and really gamble against
this economy that we're facing
by making an investment like building
this patio otherwise
my business at 25 percent will never be
able to survive
this isn't the first time reyes has had
to make changes in march he developed a
price conscious menu with restaurant
staples
as well as essential grocery items for
those that needed help
back out here live reyes says he always
wanted an outdoor dining area
but he never expected to do it out of
necessity he says that he is
very thankful for all of his customers
that have supported him in the
restaurant
as they make these changes reporting
live from chris casuelas kate houston 8
news now